the falcon in the winter soldiers final
episode tied up the series biggest
mysteries
but it left plenty of room to wonder
about a possible season two
from the mystery of the power broker to
the fate of several super soldiers
here are the biggest unanswered
questions sharing carter's
transformation from an idealist willing
to break the law in order to do what's
right to an international crime lord
is the biggest reveal in the finale
though it isn't particularly unexpected
fan speculation made her the top pick
for the power broker
her brief appearance in episode 5
practically confirmed it
and the finale makes it official not
only do we learn who she is but we
witness her murder one of the enhanced
flag smashers
carly morgenthau as well as batroc so
what exactly inspired carter's
transformation
to the power broker we get implications
that a lot of it has to do with the
aftermath of 2016's captain america
civil war
specifically we learned sharon is still
considered a traitor
while people like sam and bucky barnes
are free to go where they will along
with expressing a new negative outlook
towards superheroes in episode 3
when sam comments on her wealth she says
at some point i thought if i had to
hustle i might as well enjoy the life of
a real hustler
and in the finale when sharon confronts
carly the flag smasher says you wanted
to control a world that hurt you
but i wanted to change it but those are
the broad strokes what really happened
to sharon in madribor
going from being disillusioned to
becoming an international crime lord is
a big leap
we're betting a lot more happened to
sharon than we know and that's a story
worth hearing
it's pretty much a guarantee that a lot
of marvel comics readers watching
episode 3 of the falcon and the winter
soldier
were thinking about two names wolverine
and patch
that's because while the fictional
island of madrapor first appeared in
1985's new mutants issue 32
it's best known as the initial home of
wolverine when his first ongoing solo
title launched in 1988
meaning to operate incognito wolverine
wears an eye patch in madrid
where the inhabitants know him as patch
fans were no doubt looking for a grumpy
guy with an eye patch as sam bucky and
zemo
made their own attempt to fall the
crooks of lowtown into believing they
were other than what they appeared
of course wolverine isn't revealed in
episode 3 but that doesn't mean he isn't
there
while theories about our mutants will be
introduced to the mcu
we'll likely continue to multiply on a
daily basis we still don't know how
and when that will happen it could very
well be that logan was in a low town bar
while zemo made his famous dance moves
in high town
we'll just have to wait and see as far
as carly morgenthau and her enhanced
soldiers go the flag smashers are just
about dead
of those who survive to see the finale
sharon murders two of them
including carly and zemo's loyal butler
kills remaining four with the car bomb
so unless there's one we don't know
about running around all of the flag
smashers enhanced soldiers are dead
however from the very first episode we
see the flagsmashers have plenty of
recruits who don't have anything to do
with the super soldier serum
but they're just as dedicated to the
organization's course
not to mention that the falcon and the
winter soldier has made it clear the
infamous blip
created some complex problems granted by
the end of the finale the grc
steps back from its resettlement plans
but there's plenty of reason to think
that the kind of people recruited to the
flag smashers still have some valid
complaints
either way there's no reason to think
they'll just vanish
one of the most intriguing new
characters a falcon in the winter
soldier introduces
is contessa valentina allegra defontaine
played by julia louis-dreyfus
she's funny she knows way more than she
should and she's so mysterious that she
makes nick fury look like a used cast
salesman
unlike the senator who browbeats john
walker in episode 5
she knows walker no longer has a captain
america shield
she validates walker's homicidal actions
and in the finale
she hints that she has something to do
with the murders of the final four
flagsmasher super soldiers
in the comics val is a high ranking
member of shield but that organization's
status is still a little ambiguous in
the mcu
regardless she clearly has something to
do with some type of organization
since she not only has access to an
intelligence apparatus but the power to
put john walker back in a costume as us
agent
one tantalizing possibility is that this
has something to do with the
thunderbolts
back in 2020 rumors circulated that the
falcon and the winter soldier would
introduce the team to the mcu
but perhaps rather than introducing the
team the series has just planted the
seeds
after all while he may not technically
be seen as a super villain
john walker would certainly fit in a
group of criminals possibly seeking
redemption
when he meets with sam and bucky after
breaking out of prison in episode 3
zemo finds a mask on the dashboard of
one of his many expensive cars
and he treats it with care while it
featured heavily in the series promotion
we only see him where it once in the
actual story when he causes an explosion
to save sam bucky and sharon from the
madrupor bounty hunters
he's removed it by the time he picks up
the others in a stolen car and we never
learn exactly why it was so important to
him
why he seems to want to keep it secret
from sam and bucky or why he bothers to
wear it at all
zemo is better known as baron zemo in
the comics where he wears a similar mask
but zemo's mtu origins and motivations
stray significantly from the source
material
so that doesn't answer anything one
likely possibility is that it has
something to do with his past as a
colonel
in circovian intelligence perhaps in the
right circles zemo's mask is as
recognizable as the winter soldier's
metal arm
that would explain his hesitation to
show it to someone bucky or to wear it
in front of them
or maybe it's just a barren thing i have
a
my family was royalty until your friends
destroyed my country
in one sense this question has been
answered john walker has gone from being
a disgraced captain america to u.s
agents the same alias he uses in the
comics he's working for valentina
allegra de
fontaine though it isn't clear exactly
what he'll be doing
or even who fontaine really is
apparently the government is okay with
this as no one arrests him for showing
up to fight the flag smashers in new
york city
still it's clear not all is well with
john walker while he's thrilled to get a
second chance he still hasn't taken any
kind of responsibility for his actions
to sam and bucky and later to congress
walker justifies murdering the
surrendered flag smasher
and never backs down from his position
he even lies to lamar hoskins family
telling them the man he murdered is the
one who killed lamar not to mention as
far as we can tell he still hasn't told
anyone about using the super soldier
serum
emotionally speaking walker is a time
bomb between his actions his lies
and the impact of the super soldier
serum us agent probably has another
major meltdown on the way
and it's going to be ugly when it hits
toward the end of the finale sam gives
isaiah bradley and his grandson eli a
surprise
he brings them to the smithsonian where
he reveals a new addition to the captain
america exhibit
one honoring bradley and the other black
men who are experimented upon in the
hopes of creating more super soldiers
the exhibit includes a statue of isaiah
and an accompanying description that
reads
isaiah bradley is an american hero whose
name went unknown for too long
the moment is overwhelming for isaiah
who embraces the same man he angrily
kicked out of his house a few episodes
earlier
does this mean isaiah bradley no longer
has to live as a man presumed dead
in the penultimate episode he tells sam
he'd be killed if he ever went public
with his story
and yet that story is now public
knowledge presumably some did something
as the new captain america to make sure
isaiah would be safe
otherwise isaiah would probably have a
much different reaction to seeing his
life story
literally on display but whatever sam
does we never hear about him
perhaps sam figures that once the story
is public that alone will safeguard
isaiah since it might be considered
pointless to assassinate him when the
proverbial cat is already out of the bag
however that would seem a pretty big
risk to take with someone else's life
marvel has yet to officially announce
any kind of film or tv project revolving
around the young avengers
but they've been planting the seeds for
years in episode 2 of the falcon and the
winter soldier
we meet isaiah bradley's protective
grandson eli
in the comics a young bradley becomes a
superhero patriot
one of the founding members of the young
avengers initially eli lies to his
teammates
telling them that his grandfather's
abilities passed on down the family line
in 2005's young avengers issue 8 however
it's revealed patriots never had any
powers and instead he's been using a
drug called mutant growth hormone to
temporarily give himself enhanced
abilities
after this is discovered he quits the
team in disgrace but soon rejoins
not long after in 2006's young avengers
issue 11
patriot takes a shot from a cree soldier
meant for steve rogers
in the following issue his grandfather
agrees to donate his blood for a
transfusion
and eli developed super soldier
abilities shortly afterward
we have no idea if elijah richardson was
cast with the future young avengers
project in mind
but with more and more of the team
popping in the mcu it certainly seems
likely
just before the final credits the title
card displays something a little
different from what we're used to
it reads captain america and the winter
soldier honoring that sam has taken on
the role of cap
but we have to wonder why it doesn't
instead read captain america and bucky
or if bucky doesn't have a superhero
ring to it they could have used the name
given to him in wakanda
captain america and the white wolf while
winter soldier may sound cooler than
bucky
it's not a name bucky or anyone in his
circle uses except when discussing the
brainwashed hydra puppet
of bucky's past whenever bucky says that
name it's with guilt and shame
by the end of the finale bucky has
finally given his heartbreaking
confession to yori
and judging by the book he leaves his
therapist that was only one of many
similar conversations he had
off camera but it may be that his
unchanged name in the title is a sign
that he still has some work to do
before the winter soldier is truly dead
at the end of 2019's avengers end game
steve rogers is clearly not the young
man he once was but after the events of
the falcon and the winter soldier
no one can seem to agree on whether or
not he's alive he's referred to as being
gone multiple times
but no one ever refers to him being dead
the avengers could have lied about his
death to the public to give him a
well-earned quiet retirement
he could be in another timeline he could
be on another planet
or some people they think that he's
in secret base on the moon all the
possibilities on the steve was alive
side of things
might sound like wishful thinking but
plenty of fans are bullying for it
some of them theorize for example that
rogers is hanging out with nick fury and
the scrolls from the post-credits scenes
of 2019 spider-man far from home
by keem torres played by danny ramirez
practically screams cool sidekick and
there's a good reason for that
torrez's comic book counterpart first
appears in person in 2015's captain
america sam wilson issue 3.
experimented on by the mad scientist
carl malus torres is a human bird hybrid
who becomes the next marvel superhero
known as the falcon
the makers of the falcon and the winter
soldier couldn't have hinted any more
loudly that their torres will likewise
take up the mantle that sam wilson
leaves behind in the finale
in the penultimate episode sam tells
torres to keep the wings that john
walker tore up earlier
with a little technical know-how torres
could be joining captain america in the
sky soon
after watching the finale it definitely
seems like this show will be getting a
second season
after all the new title in the end
credits feels like a strong hint that
there will be a season two
and more than that captain america and
the winter soldier feels like a series
positively begging for more
while the marvel shows on disney plus
were initially announced as mini-series
the concept of this captain america and
the winter soldier
doesn't seem as finite as some of the
others it may seem silly for example to
expect a season 2 of one division
but the story of captain america and the
winter soldier doesn't feel complete
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one